music writing performances and newspaper
articles are published online every day
the digital revolution has led to a new
way of consuming artistic and
journalistic content whether online or
offline authors artists and journalists
should be paid fairly for their work
this is why the Parliament voted to
update online copyright rules that date
back seventeen years we would like that
the platform's take more responsibility
on the content of the platform and
second we would like to avoid
infringement of copyright protected
works from the beginning the Parliament
wants to ensure that content sharing
platforms and news aggregators don't
deprive artists of remuneration when
using their content digital companies
would have to ensure that any uploaded
copyrighted material is blocked if no
fee has been paid press publishers
should also be able to claim
remuneration if platforms use their
content it's a valid situation between
two fundamental rights so on the one
hand side this freedom of expression on
the other hand the property authors and
performers would also have stronger
negotiation rights to strengthen their
position when dealing with large
powerful platforms they will be able to
terminate exclusivity clauses or claim
more remuneration if what they have
received is disproportionately low in an
attempt to encourage startups and
innovation the text exempts small and
micro platforms from the directive
online encyclopedias or open source
software platforms like Wikipedia and
github will be exempt from the rules the
proposal also offers exceptions for
content used for education and cultural
institutions like museums and libraries
[Music]